if you actually are happy it's the
weekend or are pumped to go on vacation
your [ __ ] is broken if you hate your
Monday through Friday you're in big
trouble
your big [ __ ] trouble I [ __ ] hate
Friday I really do I'm blown away by
people celebrating the end of the week
it breaks my heart my friends like live
for Friday night like they know they got
their wait like Monday morning is the
worst like at its basic form if you
genuinely celebrate Friday you need to
rethink your entire [ __ ] game to live
your life where you love Friday night
Saturday and Sunday and despise Monday
through Thursday or Friday morning is
devastating to me because you're wasting
too much of your life and I'm trying to
put pressure on the conversation to say
if you love Friday that much then you
need to really look at Monday through
Thursday if you literally start your
week being sad and it gets progressively
better you're in a of a problem we spend
way too much time in our lives doing our
jobs and when you're spending more than
half your life working it's important
that that thing is on point it's just a
math game if you're spending eighty
three percent of your time seventy two
percent of your times sixty four percent
of your time on something you hate
that's devastating how do people not
understand that when you eliminate
sleeping it is what you do you basically
live to work mm-hmm
if you're unhappy where are you going if
you are like running to Friday night
that means you're miserable Monday
through Friday and I'd lived that life I
used to run into Friday when I was in
school and I hated Sunday night with my
entire heart I lived for snow days for
like a decade like for a decade the only
thing I gave a [ __ ] about was please
cannanore Easter come through and
eliminate school the thought that that
is so many people's work lives which
will be the disproportion percentage of
how they live their lives breaks my
heart it breaks my heart I'm not making
this video to share how lucky I am or
how cool it is that I love what I'm
doing I just don't understand why people
relegate into losing mentality and just
thinking they can
you can't because you want to be on the
bowling team or softball and play video
games that's why you can't there's
plenty of time get [ __ ] done now do you
watch a little Gary Vee you get a little
motivated you decide to actually work on
Friday night but then you wake up
Saturday right and you're feeling good
and then you grab your phone and you go
on Instagram and the first thing you see
is your boys are the people that you
look up to in the club pretty girls
jewelry and money and and all of a
sudden your phone gap you know
motivation is exciting but the
practicality of an execution it is even
more importantly in so I sit here today
and I make this video if I can get one
person to be like [ __ ] he's right like
what the hell am I doing here
Friday cannot be the best day of the
week because if it is you've already
lost and you need to figure out how to
fix that whether that side hustle from
7:00 p.m. to midnight and whether that's
networking from 7 to 9 p.m. with other
job opportunities and whether that's
taking a financial step backwards to
take a job that you love that you can
grow up into please recognize the world
we're living in this is not your
grandpappy's life we have the internet
you can make [ __ ] happen you can build
businesses or side hustles your
grandparents couldn't do the things you
can do your cream cannon didn't have the
internet your grandparents couldn't be
practical 9:00 to 5:00 then come home
you know do their family thing and then
from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning do
something online that could have been
the thing that switched them out of
their nine-to-five and created their
freedom they didn't have that option we
do everybody in this room does we live
in a 24/7 world and people get mad at me
again because like Gary [ __ ] I look
forward to the weekends I love my family
it's not about money you're such an
[ __ ] it's family I'm like no no
you're not listening I'm talking about
if you genuinely dislike what you do so
much that you beg for Friday look and
the only way you're gonna work 15 hours
a day and pay that sacrifice to be away
from your loved ones and travel and
hustle is if you're doing something
around a subject matter that you live
and breathe and die for please take this
permission
this energy to start crying and don't
give up be patient please do not waste
the next 5 10 15 20 30 years of your
life and allocate 30 40 50 60 percent of
your time to something that you hear can
end each and every week
[Music]